welcome to this video and this is Alexa
it's one of the old-timers in the ICC
playing therefore for ages really it's
got almost 10,000 and this year some
some of the account said all-time high
from 2000 so 15 years ago yeah my oldest
accounts on the ICC is from 1998 but oh
wait with it just just a moment that
this is not really grade yet I can go
here for him check my first account on
the SC was 1998 huh but of course it's
long time gone okay i guess ii 5 there
for Bishop d3 that looks quite dangerous
this position not sure if I want to take
but let's start with that
yeah so in some cases I can just take
that on your form if you go see for I
can definitely do that a question is how
to how to set up my pieces hmmm I wonder
if a 505 is a move maybe let's do that a
45 I think 96 I can take twice on your
form and win this pawn maybe has some
compensation but I'm not sure about that
no it's surprising I thought this just
was just bad why am I not just winning
the pawn here ruki one and I'm winning
the pawn or not III i have f 3 that's
leading nowhere that's quite surprising
and III I even have queen age 7 made by
the way after i have made that means
actually that f3 was a pretty good move
f3 was maybe even better than yeah yeah
this is not bad at all but I could have
just played a 3 that would have been
would have been stronger okay so 94 f 5
amazing okay rook takes he can take on
g5 night takes f5 is it really working
move like bishop age 6 Josh replied f3
yard was much stronger than rookie one
but I simply die play this too quickly
simply simply played it too quickly and
f3 now he's got rookie aid not sure that
this helps me but this seems nice
disrupting his coordination
why it is still quite comfortable
because of my my good night here on f4 I
have good dark squared controlling this
Bishop on b7 at the moment is not doing
much check them okay take that first and
then maybe Bishop to e3 let's blame me
for 95 but I have route 85 then which is
quite annoying yeah i think the apron is
more of a problem than an asset I can
play 93 attacking my queen haha okay so
it's not that easy then then just let's
take them no problem so okay look look
here I guess and then my queen should
try to activate itself but how exactly
Queenie to g4 maybe over to the Kings
side
a five I have rugby six not sure how
much okay maybe look before it's
actually a move trying to win the pawn
okay that he prevents I can give this
check but this is not this is maybe not
leading to that much I can still invade
dad's do that that's an over the tempo
here on f6 maybe queen c7 the a porn is
dangerous but his dark squared
weaknesses are also important really not
sure about this
it might be good for him but I'm really
not i really don't know unclear to me so
root b 6 is the idea
so queen is 72 Queen 87 one of those
queen e seven maybe also keeping bishop
age six ideas in the pocket there's also
an idea rook takes a form look a for
Bishop a form and okay that's not
happening I don't have a really great
square down I mean I can go here of
course but I have been up in there
anyway to play for when yeah i really
want to Queen you cept i mean ii seven
looks right down difficult difficult to
avoid
yeah maybe I can tempt him to play for
win yeah rook takes a for as an idea
here in this position rook a for Bishop
f4 b7 ok so let's go back just secure
the back rang for a moment and rook
takes a voice is coming at the right
moment or roots is six not sure what's
better ok he prevented this one to not
come over there
I've got Queen f4 h6 as a possibility
his King is not so secure that said so
one important factor I hope my rook is
not playing let's that's an issue check
check Bishop age 6 not sure Jack I know
he's got Queen f7 that wasn't a good
idea now that was bad that was really
really bad check
the situation is still not not super
clear because of his bad King but it's
quite clear that I haven't haven't
exactly gained in the last couple of
moose Bishop c5 Jack maybe somehow check
check check aah chak chak Oh ma'am
blundering the Queen there either was
bad it was really bad he sounds badly
played by me I totally did not make
something all my chances and this is
definitely good for white because of his
bad King I'm very sure maybe let's see
them I really would like to understand
this a little bit better especially
after you and age five I don't believe
that that very much around here
shouldn't shouldn't I have something
maybe he has enough counter playing I'm
not sure now i'm attacking without the
rook that's it that's really a problem
and i really would have got i would like
to maybe I took too long here and I
should really just give up the exchange
I'm not sure the problem was always this
kind of thing my back rank maybe now
somehow I didn't have the opportunity
later
check yeah let's reach out clear at all
not clear though I mean it's probably
some kind of perpetual but I wanted to
win of course yeah I mean okay in terms
of what what what what should have
happened is that of course here I'm just
winning with m3 and he basically resigns
but I saw that too late the mating idea
sorry too late errors this is also very
good but still f3 is just kind of it's
the complete reputation of blacks play
he cannot take checkmate and what is his
move from we can play a five but I mean
this is just over check and he basically
resides like here chap and i'm i'm i'm
i'm just killing him okay six Queen f7
and stuff yeah f3 was was decisive
already and this should be because this
is just a bad opening variation the move
b6 is a mistake in this position it is
played quite often even by strong
players but it's simply just a mistake
after you for white is clearly better
already Black has no way to fight the
center adequately check as we have seen
in the game around here it's already
very difficult for him to to play
anything anything decent as c4 is losing
the game actually directly but I just f3
and that's it or Bishop e3 I was simply
I didn't see that this is a maid right
this is also very good if he moves this
then I still can player three yeah yeah
okay that was a case where I played too
quickly as just saw that that rookie one
is good and I went for it and I can
still play f3 actually it's still
interesting then this is this is also
quite good but kind of complicated now
here I'm better on the dark squares and
a five that's also right TX takes
somewhere here I can also improve i'm
pretty sure maybe queen here the
computer gives this month it just can
of strong looking at the not there
looking at the bishop preventing 95
there was also an opportunity okay
whatever thanks for watching